so on the one hand you might say yes
whatever theories we have at a given
time even if they are a best established
theories the best were working with you
know perhaps there's some successor
theory which will have some other
features than the current theory we're
looking at so that's one thing that
we're being urged to look at by Jared
and it could be that in whatever the
successor theory is it's business as
normal with regards to the status of the
observer visa via the rest of reality
it's something like a return to
classical physics well maybe but the
question is on what basis do we make
that judgment and it doesn't seem to me
that things need be like that maybe it'd
be nice if they were so but maybe maybe
we can actually be more excited by what
if you look at the content of many
general claims that would take to hold
given quantum mechanics is predictive
success that in fact a more natural
thing to think is that there isn't any
more fundamental microscopically non
very complete theory to be had what do I
mean by that we have the process of
looking at the general claims made by
quantum mechanics and looking at the
confirmed experimental predictions
formulating a yet more general
theoretical scheme in which these can be
embedded and explained and then drawing
conclusions about what further kinds of
theories could possibly produce the
results that we've seen in experiments
these are called no-go and theorems and
logo experiments in quantum theory where
you're trying to pin down not features
of quantum mechanics itself but features
of what the world itself needs to be
like in virtue of the predictions of
quantum mechanics being confirmed
experimentally and it seems to me that
the output of these theoretical and
experimental results is in many ways
very naturally explained by saying there
isn't a fundamental complete completion
there isn't a fundamental set of laws at
the microscopic level describing
everything which behave in much the way
that physics tradition has taken it to
do and what's the problem with that so I
want to ask you Jared why the insistence
for for this atavistic notion of the
underlying physics
well I find that alternatives are much
worse so I think the best of all
possible worlds that I can imagine will
be a completely deterministic one and
once you say party deterministic then
you fail completely when you say okay
deterministic but in Bell's famous
Gedanken experiment Bob and Alice still
have the free will to choose their
orientations then I say wait a minute
now you're violating something and now
you putting yourself in a difficult
position and if you look very carefully
at the mathematics I came that Bell
didn't have his definition of causality
correct so causality to him means that
the future will not affect the past but
of the past will affect the future that
sounds reasonable but it isn't in our
models yes but in the world as soon as
you change anything in the present you
must have had that preceded by change in
the past otherwise a change could have
happened so the the problem the bellows
was struggling with was that he didn't
want to change the past but it did
evolve change the decisions that Bob and
Alice make to measure something that is
forbidden and that itself is a very
strange thing that that makes it very
hard to us to make models which show
that so Belle thought because those
arguments those models are impossible
and I claim no we haven't searched hard
enough but I don't think they're
impossible so hey you wanted to say that
quantum mechanics may have appeared to
its discoverers and generation of
science afterwards to involve this sort
of randomness if you like but you're
saying they just need to peel back that
layer and underneath there will be some
rules which are deterministic we so like
the rules up here you have to actively
search for that if you don't do that
you'll never you never do such a thing
friends you get string theories things
he is also fundamentally quantum
mechanical so this is why I have my
doubts also for string theories well
you're not they're not there yet
yet by long
you